cool play from both sides not committing  anything yet  and i think magnus for sure he's got a  strategy in mind he's going to try and  play it against artemis clock a bit  later on what is he doing okay meanwhile  magnus just swiveling on that chair  oh i've got a temptation to do the same  now but uh we see the secret love chair  as well i think all of the players  are going to be using that throughout  the tour  it's a very comfortable chair yeah super  comfortable perfect for gaming perfect  for esports  and online chess so  yeah magnus just distracted there for a  second  i don't think there was anything  suspicious going on there i think he was  just getting a bottle of water or  something